e
[Aplausos]
quando eu passei no meu primeiro emprego
o estágio na TV Globo Eu lembro que eu
contei para os meus pais e claro eles
ficaram super felizes Parabéns aquela
coisa mas eu lembro que uma das
primeiras coisas que a minha mãe me
disse foi filha Ok você passou no seu
primeiro emprego então agora a gente
precisa sair para comprar roupa de
trabalhar eu nunca tinha trabalhado Na
vida eu pensei será essa tal roupa de
trabalhar na aqui tá errado a minha
roupa e aí a gente pegou e foi para o
shopping eu falei tá bom então vamos lá
comprar essa roupa de trabalhar e aí eu
lembro que a gente chegou no shopping e
aí minha mãe começou a sair atrás de
camisa social calça social salto e eu só
olhando né tá bom e fazem eu preciso
começar a trabalhar então vamos seguir E
aí a gente foi para o provador aí no
provador eu colocando aquelas roupas que
eu nunca tinha colocado E aí eu lembro
que começou a provocar uma comoção no
provador com outras mulheres que estavam
lá minha mãe claro super orgulhosa
contando para todo mundo aí minha filha
passou na Globo ela vai começar a
trabalhar e aí as pessoas olhando para
mim com aquela roupa de trabalhar
falando Nossa você tá linda desse jeito
eu tenho certeza que vai dar tudo certo
você vai ser uma grande profissional
como se por colocar aquela roupa como se
por se vestir daquela maneira Já fosse
certeza de que eu seria competente de
que eu seria uma grande profissional de
que eu teria uma carreira maravilhosa de
certa maneira eu também acreditei
naquilo por muito tempo então eu
acreditei que eu precisava me vestir
daquela maneira
é porque o jeito que eu me vestia talvez
não seria suficiente Se eu quisesse
crescer como profissional então eu
lembro que eu comecei a minha carreira
sendo quem as pessoas achavam que eu
deveria ser mas não sendo quem eu era de
verdade
e aí eu lembro que eu fui trabalhar meu
primeiro dia
super desconfortável com aquela roupa
era como se eu não me encaixasse ali
dentro de certa maneira então eu tava no
ônibus de salto
com camisa suando aquele calor e aí meio
desconfortável não sabia direito como
ficar com a roupa e tal mas não fui
É nesse eu fui
já passou muito tempo anos e anos
da Mari fantasiada de algo que ela
achava que precisava ser para alcançar
alguma coisa e não da Mari sendo a Maria
de verdade
a e é muito curioso porque por muito
tempo eu fui trabalhar de salto era
assim que meus amigos me conheciam mas
não era como eu me vestia normalmente eu
queria estar ali né fantasiada de
profissional competente mesmo que fosse
contra quem eu sou de verdade
trabalhando na Globo eu fui convidado
então para participar de um projeto
o que seria o G1 em 1 minuto e aí me
convidaram para fazer um piloto desse
projeto Mari a gente precisa que você
vem amanhã para fazer um piloto eu não
sabia direito o que era e tal e a gente
precisa que você venha um piloto de
vídeo para você ser apresentadora de um
projeto em rede nacional
falei nossa que que eu fiz
corri para a sessão credibilidade do meu
armário digamos assim peguei todas as
roupas que eu achava que me faziam
parecer séria com credibilidade e tal
cheguei arrasando no dia e aí eu lembro
que um dos meus chefes olhou para mim
falou assim
e não Maria a gente não quer você assim
a gente quer você de verdade e aí eu
sabe olhei para de baixo para cima sim
falei sério aí ele falou sério esse
projeto a gente quer que você seja de
verdade a gente é você com as suas
roupas a gente quer você falando do
jeito que você fala aí eu falei nossa
será enfim voltei para casa
coloquei as minhas camisetas de banda de
série tal vestir a minha roupa sem a
fantasia e aí eu comecei naquele desafio
naquele projeto com uma sensação um
pouco complexa dentro de mim porque ao
mesmo tempo que eu tava muito feliz
porque eu tinha de certa maneira me
libertado daquela caixa que eu achei por
muitos anos que eu precisava entrar que
eu precisava estar
mas ao mesmo tempo eu estava com muito
medo da rejeição porque a gente passa a
vida inteira tentando ser aceito a gente
passa a vida inteira tentando pertencer
ao o
e dentro da minha fantasia profissional
eu pertencia de certa maneira algum
grupo eu tava ali como profissional
competente então sem aquela proteção
digamos assim eu tava sem nenhum muro
entre mim e o público
e isso me assustava eu tinha muito medo
da rejeição eu tinha medo de confirmar
aquilo que por muito tempo acreditei que
eu não seria suficiente
é como uma menina de piercing
tatuagem aparente no braço camiseta de
série de banda pode entrar na televisão
falando de política economia eu vou
acreditar no que ela disse e olha só que
curioso eu mesma cair nessa armadilha eu
no começo do projeto também acreditei
que eu não merecia falar sobre esses
assuntos mais complexos mais densos por
causa do jeito que eu me vestia
E então eu comecei esse projeto
totalmente desacreditado em mim
é só que eu fui de novo fechei o olho e
eu fui e foi o começo
de uma jornada que me fez entender o
poder dessa palavrinha que a gente
escuta hoje bastante que é autenticidade
e eu lembro que no começo do G1 em 1
minuto
uma Senhorinha ligou na redação
eu tô meio do dia sim e ela falou para o
meu chefe
pede para essa menina tirar esse Arame
do nariz porque eu não tenho nada a ver
com ela
e eu lembro que meu chefe desligou dando
risada
aí eu olhei para ele falei que foi chefe
ele falou a ligou uma senhora que
falando para você tirar esse Arame do
nariz Aí eu virei para ele falei assim
eu tiro aí ele não não tira
e eu parei falei nossa tá bom
ó e aqui eu acho muito importante dizer
o seguinte
e não foi de um dia para o outro que eu
simplesmente acordei e falei quer saber
eu vou desafiar o sistema vou comprar
todos os códigos todos os obstáculos que
existem eu vou passar por tudo isso vou
colocar minha camiseta de banda vou
aparecer na televisão e o povo que lute
não eu tive uma oportunidade e Eu Tenho
total consciência da sorte que eu tive
de ter pessoas no meu caminho que viram
algo em mim que eu mesma não conseguia
enxergar
o que viam que a Mari Podia sim ser
suficiente a Mari de verdade
Ah e não só as pessoas com quem eu
trabalhava enxergaram isso público
também começou a enxergar o poder dessa
autenticidade porque o medo que eu tinha
de ser rejeitada
e ele meio que ficou para trás porque as
pessoas começaram a se identificar
comigo de certa maneira então nas minhas
redes sociais que né eu colocava ali
foto da minha família do meu cachorro e
tal eu tinha sei lá 300 e 400 seguidores
esse número começou a subir subir subir
subir subir e aí as pessoas começaram a
me seguir a me mandar mensagem eu falei
nossa existe um movimento aqui tem
alguma coisa acontecendo aqui que eu não
tô entendendo direito que é e a maioria
das mensagens
dizendo que se identificavam comigo que
se viu em mim ou mães e avós dizendo que
viam as filhas e netas em mim os filhos
e netos
os alunos de jornalismo
dizem delmare eu quero fazer Jornalismo
e falei para o meu pai que eu quero
fazer uma tatuagem ele disse para mim
que eu jamais você jornalista assim hoje
eu pego a sua foto mostra que para ele
falou ela tá lá eu também posso
é uma vez não evento eu
encontrei uma menina que disse que foi
ao evento só para conversar comigo
e é quando ela me viu ela pegou na minha
mão e ela treme assim começou a chorar
aí eu falei que que aconteceu tá tudo
bem aí ela falou queria te agradecer aí
eu falei porque
aí ela falou eu faço engenharia e eu me
visto de um jeito que as pessoas
questionam as pessoas falam de como eu
me visto e vendo você fazendo que você
faz fazendo que você faz com brilho no
olho algo que você ama isso me dá força
para resistir para seguir em frente
Oi e esse tipo de retorno que começou
aparecer me deu uma força absurda sim
para continuar me fez entender que sim
eu poderia ser suficiente
me fez entender que tinha valor na Mari
de verdade
E aí olha que curioso a gente precisa
muitas vezes que a outra pessoa vale de
a gente para a gente ir acreditar em
quem a gente é
e geralmente parte do outro né da pessoa
olhar para você e falar eu gosto de você
assim legal continue se a pessoa de
repente Falar ao contrário você vai se
questionava e duvidar de quem você é
bom então eu continuei eu resisti por
causa de todo esse apoio que eu tive
inicialmente que foi um apoio que me fez
entender o poder da autenticidade então
eu percebi que eu não precisava mais
recorrer a sessão credibilidade do meu
guarda-roupa porque a credibilidade
estava em mim não no jeito que eu me
vestia eu podia sim ser competente eu
podia falar de política e economia eu
podia fazer tudo isso usando o piercing
fazendo tatuagem e de camiseta e tênis
isso não me fazia menos competente
a perceber isso foi muito transformador
não só para minha carreira mas para
minha vida também porque eu comecei a
perceber como muitas vezes a gente
limita a gente mesmo e limita o outro
E então alguém que tem coragem de ser de
verdade alguém que tem coragem de
assumir o jeito que se veste de falar do
jeito que fala muitas vezes a gente tem
um olhar Cruel sobre essa pessoa né
é isso também significa um olhar Cruel
sobre a gente mesmo
então eu percebi o poder que esse
movimento da autenticidade pode ter para
tudo para as nossas relações para nossa
profissão
e não só para gente Para todo mundo e eu
entendi que muitas vezes a gente pode
ser a barreira para o outro ser de
verdade então que a gente não seja essa
barreira que a gente não seja mais um
obstáculo porque já tem tanto obstáculo
né impedindo e dizendo para gente que a
gente não é suficiente então que a gente
não seja mas não está culo para o outro
agora a gente fala tanto sobre
autenticidade a gente fala tanto sobre
essa coragem esse processo que ao mesmo
tempo que é tão difícil é tão gostoso
por quê que é tão difícil fazer isso
porque isso significa derrubar o muro e
quando você derruba esse muro
a recepção pode ser positiva mas ela
pode ser muito negativa também
Ah e eu não estou dizendo aqui que eu só
tive elogio que as pessoas me amaram sem
por cento não eu tive muita reação
negativa a isso pessoas dizendo que eu
não merecia tá naquele lugar falando de
política e economia
pessoas me chamando de estagiária
por causa do jeito que eu me visto
sempre que eu já tinha quase 10 anos de
carreira e sempre que eu trabalhava
muito apesar de estar um minuto na
televisão eu juro que eu trabalho a
maior do que isso
também aconteceu contrário pessoas
dizendo ela só tá aí por causa da
camiseta eu coloco uma camiseta e um
tênis eu vou na frente da câmera eu falo
tá do mesmo
Olá tudo isso me fez duvidar por muito
tempo ainda me faz às vezes novidade
quem eu sou não acreditar nesse valor
que eu venho encontrando com o tempo
mas depois de muita terapia e faça um
terapia
e eu apertar sabe que essa crítica
negativa só pela crítica ela falava
muito mais sobre a outra pessoa do que
sobre mim e percebi outra coisa também
que foi muito importante para mim
e eu preferia receber um comentário ruim
sobre quem eu sou de verdade respeitando
a minha identidade
é do que receber um elogio sobre uma
personagem que eu criei
porque aí a pessoa tá elogiando outra
pessoa não eu e essa outra pessoa ela
não existe e é muito difícil sustentar
essa pessoa a gente gasta muita energia
bancando
personagem sempre a gente podia tá
usando essa energia de outra maneira
se cansa
o seu outra pessoa
e não dá a gente não aguenta muito tempo
então pensando por esse lado é muito
mais fácil de verdade porque é isso que
a gente quer a gente quer cada vez mais
conexões autênticas a gente quer olhar
no olho da outra pessoa e se enxergar
enxergar fragilidade enxergava
onerabilidade
enxergar humanidade a gente não quer se
relacionar com um robô a gente não quer
se relacionar com todo mundo igual
e eu desde que comecei nesse movimento
já há quase 10 anos
eu sou do time que acolhe a diferença
que acolhe o desafio de todo mundo
desse autêntico porque eu acho que se eu
acolheu o outro essas pessoas também não
me acolher claro que existem muitos
códigos muitas barreiras muitos
obstáculos é eu não tô dizendo aqui para
você que trabalha no escritório de
advocacia simplesmente pegar sua
camiseta do Foo Fighters no dia seguinte
aparecer lá e falar que é saber amar e
disse que tudo bem não é isso
e eu acho que é importante que a gente
encontre dentro do nosso caminho as
possibilidades
é de colocar a nossa identidade no que a
gente faz dentro da realidade que a
gente vive a gente sabe que
infelizmente no Brasil as realidades são
completamente diferentes Então eu queria
lançar uma reflexão o quanto de você
você já deixou de lado pelo medo de ser
julgado pelo medo de não ser aceito e
mais o quanto você já teve um olhar
Cruel sobre outra pessoa que tava ali só
tentando ser ela mesma
e eu acho que parar para pensar nisso é
um primeiro passo para a gente falar
sobre autenticidade
a ser hipocrisia minha dizer que é um
processo simples que é fácil não é como
eu disse eu tô nessa mais de dez anos e
eu ainda recebo críticas negativas eu
ainda questionam quem eu sou eu ainda
tenho dúvidas sobre a minha capacidade
por causa do jeito que eu me visto
é mas eu venho me fortalecendo e eu acho
que esse é um processo que vai levar
minha vida inteira
Oi e eu digo que mesmo com essas
dificuldades mesmo com esse caminho que
nem sempre é fácil nem sempre é cheio de
flores
uma hora o céu se abre
bom então eu posso garantir que vale a
pena Obrigada e